alors elle riposté un amour parce que il
a fait la production ce matin il a dit
j'ai vous avez rendez des gâteaux pour
tout le monde
oui j'ai ramené des gâteaux avec julie à
camiers jubilé fidh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
attendez que tout le monde ait mangé sa
grand mère il ya une saloperie de simon
vigie mada temps détendent et en dessin
de cyril hanouna marquis les assurances
et julie qui la met sérieux maintenant
mais soyons et moi j'ai les yeux dans
les yeux sinon est ce que ces gâteaux
sont les vrais rendrai année le match et
qui se sent mal en
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gentil a un nouveau maire nos grands
mères ont passé des heures et des heures
à faire ces gâteaux avec amour et
passion je te connais tu es un homme bon
ganis gros john catoe je nourris le
change par r
dieu
je dessine je lui ai parlé
[Applaudissements]
mais dans la foulée on respecte on n'est
pas en direct mais se comporte bien avec
enrico on a raté mission d'angelina sans
rigoler ya juliette gréco qui vous avez
gardé bien tout ça vous manger des
gâteaux moi je vais manger ça suffit
allez dans ok ok prenez
[Rires]
et b pris l'habitude mort dans le mien
je jure bazille juste vas-y je ne porte
jamais isabelle il va donne dans le but
d'aller voir aller si gbagbo a irrité le
look sentent un peu le point
[Rires]
promise à écouter une bassine et
franchement ça sent la vue basse au pied
du poisson mort anonyme bonjour il est
très bon c'est de la faire ben hammam a
demandé qu'on nous a envoyé la vidéo de
ta part à schongau julie giroux le
message qui disait je veux absolument
que les 7 bons donnent pas le
chroniqueur ces gros tarbes a donc j'ai
pris l'huile de foie de morue et je suis
en tous les cas nos gènes
[Applaudissements]
averts à dougga moi j'aime bien wel
moudja oui allez j'ai mangé nommé en
octobre à pizza vous râlez bon point
trop n'en faut